time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week
first up putting your health in your
hands a new study out this week from the
American Cancer Society looked at the
number of cases and deaths where
modifiable risk factors played a role I
guess that's things you can change yeah
the researchers use 2014 data to draw
those conclusions they found that an
estimated 42 percent of all cancer cases
are a result of risk factors we
potentially control and that an even
higher 45% of cancer deaths are a result
of these factors joining us to discuss
the findings at CBS News contributor dr.
David agus doc so I think this is good
news as far as people who want to be
able to say I can affect my health
outcomes what are the risk factors why
it's good news if it's bad news because
we're not doing it so this same study
was done about several decades ago and
what they showed is what I was smoking
smoking smoking was the dominant risk
factor and over the last couple decades
has gone down but obesity related
cancers have gone up and they've kind of
taken the place of smoking so the big
ones are smoking obesity lack of
movement sitting or being stagnant all
day and things like HPV vaccine right
you get a vaccine you can prevent cancer
so those are the critical ones we hit
those we're gonna dramatically decrease
the incidence of cancer in this country
and I shouldn't really be sitting down
for this next topic but I guess I'm
gonna have to it is I think we have just
before we get to our next topic let's
let's just wrap up but you're welcome to
stay our cancer conversation are there
certain cancers that are more implicated
than others when we talk about these
risk factors yeah so lung cancer is the
big one
right I mean lung cancer 85 90 percent
is related to smoking smoking in this
country is still there you know 19
percent of kids in high school still
smoke which is an astonishing figure if
you think about it so we need to
decrease smoking things like colon
cancer breast cancer or can be related
to obesity and what we eat so both of
those are again addressable we get away
from the processed meats and other
things colon cancer rates will go down
if we you know move
more if we can and we have less obesity
we're gonna get less breast cancer which
is going to be dramatic now I am
obviously eager to get on to the next
subject but I have one more question on
this current topic the answer is yes we
know we know that overeating and smoking
the tides of cancer that message is out
there how do we make sure people are
actually getting it well I mean you hit
it right is that the problem is is that
if I tell you to do something today it's
not going to help you until a decade two
three decades from now that lag in
health is really killing us in the big
respective things so how do we do that I
mean we need to educate and to really
get people to understand and so when you
tell patients what to do they just roll
their eyes you explain to them why
hopefully behavior changed yeah
literally you can decrease your risk for
cancer if you do this yes okay all right
it's a time can we go time I want to
talk about before it really should not
be sitting down for this one our next
topic taking a stand for your health
many workplace environments require
employees to work at a desk no surprise
there that can mean a lot of sitting
which has been implicated as a health
risk a new study published by biomed
central examined a select group of
German desk workers it compared the time
they desire to spend sitting standing
and doing physical activity versus the
reality desire versus the reality I
would like to do a lot more walking
around what do they find well I mean
people want to walk more than they do
and I think people are also surprised
how much they said you know I got one of
these little watches and I was shocked
how much I was sitting during the day
I've got a treadmill desk at least once
a day I'd go for a walking meeting and
it makes a big impact remember we were
designed to move our bodies were
designed to move so the more you move
you actually decrease cancer and heart
disease those data are pretty impressive
and so redesign your life never have a
printer at your desk you know have it
somewhere else in the building go to a
different floor to go to the bathroom at
work try to figure out ways to move that
seems drastic but doc I mean I I have a
standing desk and I am very thankful
that CBS has standardized for me you
have a treadmill desk not everybody can
have these things in their workplace
environment right certain jobs lend
themselves to sedentary behavior I love
that when I said you have to get up to
walk you go to the bathroom you said
that seems dress
I was gonna say maybe get a pipe for a
walk but Alex maybe not the we just need
to figure out ways to simply redesign
our life is that if you can walk for
five minutes an hour you've done a major
impact on your health so get up you know
walk around don't call someone three
offices down walk over and talk to them
yeah you know Steve Jobs we used to meet
and he used to go east go for walks they
said David there are two reasons to go
for the walks he goes the first is the
health benefits he goes the second if
you're walking and get to the corner and
you know you're gonna turn left right or
go straight it gives you an advantage in
the business negotiation oh so he had
every little angle walk down but figure
out ways to bring in walking to your
life why is it on us we should be on the
company's make they should make some
changes no question about it we redesign
the floors we do environmentally design
buildings whose doing health design
building why is why are we sitting now
should we all know I'm not gonna do that
to our camera guys dr. David agus thank
you as always for your time and thoughts